[Music]
alright man so I got this story here
bear with me it's a lot right but it's a
hilarious story and you guys are allowed
to chime in you sound very entertaining
right now he does to me yeah so I have a
very hilarious story it is
magnifico okay so my 29 ok she's she's
29 female right and her boyfriend is a
29 male keeps getting into fights with a
cook at Waffle House that's just funny
to say out loud I know this sounds
really weird but here it is my boyfriend
and I have been together for three years
we met and started dating when we were
both in graduate school but I dropped
out to go back to college to pursue a
different career
we are both finished now and live
together making a fairly nice combined
income our income is relevant because we
could afford to eat somewhere nice when
we're out and about but he always wants
breakfast food when he was a child his
dad couldn't stand eating breakfast type
food in the afternoon or evening so his
mom would make him waffles and pancakes
eggs and bacon in the evening whenever
his dad was busy or out of town it's a
wonderful and safe memory for him and
when he goes to his happy place he says
that's where he always goes okay my
boyfriend is an incredibly nice and
caring person he's emotionally tuned in
to everyone and recognizes arising
issues a long time before they occur he
loves animals and is kind and gentle
with every bug that comes across he
almost always willing to turn the other
cheek in social situations when somebody
tries to insult him or get aggressive
towards him and usually sometimes but
the other time
he even pets fish he's really nice and
usually winds up there using the
situation in having a productive
discussion about whatever the issue was
except at Waffle House any time we're
out he wants to go to the same goddamn
wall twice and get breakfast food I'm
not a big eater so I used to not really
care I would just drink coffee and read
my book while he enjoyed his food
that became impossible once he and his
one cook started chirping at each other
every time we went there
boyfriend complained about his eggs one
time because he likes them a little
runny and they were served hard the cook
responded by giving him scrambled eggs
we keep the cook served them two
hard-boiled eggs I think it was just
part of the cook shtick he hated it and
it was kind of funny to be honest but my
boyfriend wasn't able to laugh it off
when we left he was in kind of a bad
mood but we didn't really talk about it
the next week we were out getting some
shopping done and he wanted to go to the
Waffle House again I suggested that we
try a different place or at least a
different Waffle House location but he
only wanted the same Waffle House did
the chef principle did the chef put two
eggs on a plate we went in and sat down
and once again the same cook served his
eggs wrong my boyfriend sort of snapped
at him and he wasn't interested in
messing around and just wanted the
correct eggs the cooked and served him a
piece of toast with a hole cut out in
the middle my boyfriend got really mad
and threw the egg toast at the cook
which made the cook come around from
behind the bar so I'm back at him they
ended up sort of wrestling fighting
until my boyfriend was this is [ __ ]
and walked out nobody got hurt but the
few other people in there we're watching
and laughing a bit I was like a standard
day at Waffle House yeah sounds like
some Waffle House behavior resorts to
wrestling before throwing a punch people
who don't just like it's like a shoving
match like this they're just like yeah
like you don't actually want to hurt
someone and get into a lawsuit situation
so you just with all these fights that
people could just walk away from when
they're done like Nelson's fight the
previous episodes and this guy was like
I've had it just walks away from a
wrestling match you know what I said I
didn't call it a fight I just punched
them and then I was offered Oh daddy was
nothing not all of us no expert fighting
techniques
mr. high school wrestler who's trained
in the Marceline you major thing if you
were in a fight you would finish the
fight by murdering them yes can then
walk away by knockout have to die by TKO
yeah yeah it's a life or death oh we can
be sleep if I'm gonna start a fight I'm
a fight oh because I won't let it get to
the point where I'm gonna fight it so I
put my hands on someone it's not put
their hands on me I'm thinking as a
fighter who fights to the death what
else what if a woman put your hands on
me oh he's gonna melt her when I pick a
fight I feel like it's like are you
gonna do it alright man do it are you
gonna do it we played chicken until
someone actually does something anyways
so this is the crazy part she says my
boyfriend keeps going back in ordering
eggs and getting into fistfights with
the same cook it's almost a ritual at
this point my friends orders eggs the
cook serves him some other version of
eggs and then they beat the [ __ ] out of
each other I quit going with him after
the second fight but he kept going by
himself
they're like Peter and the giant chicken
from Family Guy it's the weirdest thing
they physically fought like six or seven
times after this maybe they actually
both are tactics you think so at Waffle
House you costly going to get a fight
those heroin people normally I would say
that this is reddit creative writing
because they say Waffle House I'm like
this is real right it's a hundred
percent legit if they said this was like
Houston steakhouse I wouldn't believe it
like IHOP even I thought this soul of a
more elevated yeah yeah though is a
place in the south
definitely fights out you would see that
yeah I love Waffle House though so when
she was painting this picture like we
have money we don't need Waffle House I
was like uh-uh
girl you don't know it's the Waffle
House though babe I'm still going to
Wienerschnitzel [ __ ] you I've tried to
talk to him about it a few times but he
keeps saying it's a matter of principle
I've told him to talk to the manager or
something like that it's an awesome he's
being disrespected well this guy in his
dream world this guy has to
and serve him the perfect eggs and he
has to be like that's right he's like
that's the right egg not even in the
perfect world though just according to
the guy's [ __ ] job description he
needs to make the order geo this guy is
committing right now he's committing
hard I like it I like it I think what
happened was a long time ago this guy
was driving it was maybe a little bit
rainy there was a cow in the middle of
the road and then hit a tree and then
it's 50 first dates basically and he
just keeps going back to the same spot
and then just keep doing the same thing
for the same reason as a dumb okay just
keep [ __ ] with me he's like this
guy's just like my dad
I love it on the inside I'm not gonna
talk about it so he's coming back for
this a piece of daddy misses they like
it so apparently the cook hasn't made
him the correct runny eggs but it's like
he spends the week learning new ways to
preparing different eggs to pissed her
relationship he's so creative help this
guy break out of his habits there's more
types of eggs there's more places to go
there's more things he actually tried
the AG you might have that breakthrough
like in ratatouille we has a flashback
to his childhood yeah yeah so the thing
is they're getting married this summer
is this he's accepting a job in a new
city oh [ __ ] that's the cook and the guy
it'll be easy for me to find work after
the wedding so we'll be moving away from
this swarm enemy Waffle House guy he
hasn't really been out since quarantine
started but it wouldn't surprise me if
that's the first place he goes to when
restaurants opened back up for seating
customers but my main worry is this
strange vindictive side of him I've
never seen before that leads to him to
fight the same guy every week the
violence itself is an issue for me
but the obsession over it almost bothers
me even more should I be worried that
this side of him will come up later in
our marriage how do I get him to open up
about this is this type of a session of
choice or is it indicative of something
deeper if she ever asked him or if he
ever asked her
to make food and she asked like what do
you want and he says eggs she should run
don't make dope for their wedding if she
hires the boomers come like being like
oh I'm ready for this show that happens
every week would it show us that why do
they spike - I want to see like is it a
full-on like brawl I think it's just the
chairs in the way and then I'm just
pushing each other and the chairs
falling I just wanna see him pissed off
at home afterward like I know how guys
are you know I know you gotta block some
scene about it like how when he gets the
eggs what do you think it does do you
think he just has like a kind of like
one of those like drop the pork thing
like you three get the plate the whole
way though he's just like well also the
cooks boil I was always in the kitchen
probably looking the waitress brought
the poor waitress doesn't know she
brings it I'm sure she knows now and
it's just probably like she's probably
the messenger between them that's sad
what's great that he's paying every time
right cuz he he's allowed back in that
means he's paying for the world why do
they let him back in after the second
time cuz he's still paying the money
okay where they can warm with lesson
dollars its Waffle House it's most
things are four dollars normal yeah oh I
love Waffle House though where's that
you gotta go to like anywhere but la
yeah a New Mexico even or arrow floss is
uh Breaking Bad if you go to a waffle do
they have a little applause I thought
all their places were fake yeah let's go
- wah floss Oh [ __ ] I can see that yeah
there you go yeah saw the scene
do you guys remember when the like
Flanders had to go like figure out why
he had a cussing problem or whatever or
like when he was a child he had a
cussing problem so that's why they made
him so like polite right it kind of
reminded me of this where the guy is
extra kind extra knives won't hurt a fly
that's like this is this little Fight
Club like this is his thing that he gets
to rage out on like how Canadians are
really nice until they go into the skate
rink one place break your bones man but
when they get drunk off maple cider or
maple syrups maples yeah
apple cider syrups I would try maple
cider yeah really good sounds pretty
good huh mm-hmm right now I don't know I
would like to have a fight friend that I
can tell I can do that way though but
well the thing is like their level of
fighting it sounds like no one's really
getting hurt yeah and if you fighting a
demon he'll kill you job UMass even the
fight friends that we even when we're
practicing we we get hurt yeah I want to
shoving man yeah what kind of acting you
know what the push me too far
push you know it like you just yeah
[ __ ] wrestle okay stick to the past
six of paths yeah and you get mad anger
and you stop your feet and you walk away
one of those I knew whose schedule I
would go every single time just to watch
this is the kind of [ __ ] live for I wish
they would tell us about this kind of
[ __ ] but you are local freak shows like
I want to go to those all the time
mission two I'd rather go to that than
an NFL game most weeks Hardison
[Music]